coucou c'est moi
leona c'est moi
où est il leona sors ta cachette je sais
que tu es là
[Musique]
il n'est pas dans sa base
au quel animal de l'est là
non seulement ils me réveillent à 2
heures du matin vous donner rendez vous
le lendemain mais n'est pas là au soleil
véritablement personnages étranges et
nous ne l'avons pas fait exprès je m'en
sers amis je m'en doute mais enfin j'ai
quand même heureux de vous voir revient
tant mieux non monsieur schnobb vous
avez besoin de nous oui figurez vous que
léonard m'a donné rendez vous
aujourd'hui à cette heure ci et il n'est
pas là c'est c'était un nom vous en être
sûr seulement je nie absolument
c'est trop c'est trop je me faisais pas
du tout dans les habitudes de leonard de
faire attendre mais non d'habitude c'est
toujours lui qui attend les autres oui
ils donnent rendez vous par téléphone
cinq minutes avant juste le temps
d'arriver oui et bien aujourd'hui il a
trouvé mieux que ça il a trouvé mieux
que
savez-vous qui m'a réveillé
cette nuit à 2 heures du matin aux
clients dans l'appareil que c'était
urgent effectivement c'est ceci très
extraordinaire on va écouter monsieur du
snop c'est pas difficile il n'y a qu'un
iphone os et moi fulbert en scène du
snob attendant ce mal à paris jamais de
la vie vous avouer que je suis un petit
peu fatigué cette nuit quand les
honneurs m'a réveillée à deux heures du
matin bien j'ai pas pu me rendormir je
le sois blessé léger le mot comme en
cent je parle métro les lycées
soit oui quelle nous faire l'écho du
leem si nous voulons savoir la vérité
toute la vérité il n'y a plus qu'à
attendre léonard
[Musique]
ça fait plus d'une heure que nous
l'attendons
cette fois je crois vient de sceller
un sens
oui nous sommes vous voulez je vous dise
surtout ce n'est qu'un homme stupide je
n'ai attendu une heure moi il y en a six
ans
mais léonard dessus du snob lui aussi tu
as attendu sen ni ici amaro c'est
important chez lui que nous avions
rendez vous chez lui mais il vient d'y
retourner vous savez certainement dû
vous croisez pas du tout un joli
plantagenet entraperçu l'entrée chez lui
je lui crie très en colère enfin quelle
est alors la non il n'est parti commun
comme un idiot en courant comme s'il
avait vu je ne sais quoi évidemment
évidemment tu as dû lui faire peur mais
oui tu n'aurais pas dû crier si fort en
la personne tout à fait d'accord léonard
du n'a pas de conseil à recevoir mais
moi si j'étais à ta place bien j'irai
chez monsieur du snob je l'attendrai
puis je lui présenterai mes excuses
vont présenter des excuses à ceux
cliquant à roulettes oui mais toi tu l'a
réveillée à deux heures du matin il n'a
pas pu se rendormir et lui tape
ardennais
patrimoine et qui crache dit que vu de
mes propres yeux
vous essayez vous me suis dit ce même
essayé vous voilà nous allons vous
écouter et oui votre votre fantôme et
bien c'était tout simplement léonard oui
ils nous attendaient chez vous depuis
une heure il a commencé à perdre
patience et lorsqu'il vous a vu il était
très en colère et il a crié voilà
le faire ça
va faire peur à me faire courir je suis
fatigué mais ça n'a rien monsieur 19
voulez vous que nous vous raccompagne
chez vous voilà quoi jamais je vais la
tonne il nous est il que léonard qui
tordent le cou est bien juste je bats
n'est pas noir je passe avant on va voir
ce qu'on va voir plus attendre ici
retrait chez vous entre chevaux
immédiatement c'est moi qui vais
l'attendre allez allez à votre maison
brh l'attend au
on
verra bien qui rira le dernier